what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with deceased and I'm coming
down with a cold so I may not
necessarily be as crazy and animated as
I normally am but as is the case with a
Tom Taylor comic the ending of this is
crazy that's always the case of Tom
Taylor so what we end up doing here is
we pick up with Superman there is a bit
of a Prelude when it comes to Lobo but
we'll talk about him presumably in the
next issue when he makes his appearance
as part of the main conflict but what
goes on here is it initially picks up
with Superman and this basically deals
with the destruction of volvox Vic right
now if you guys remember the last video
that we did and as always you'll find
the DC's playlist down in the
description so that if you're just
joining us you can get caught up on
everything but as we talked about in the
last video this was destroyed by Mr
mixopitalic who is one of the most
powerful beings to ever exist in the
history of DC Comics and the fact that
this guy has now been turned to the army
of the dead right like the the army of
dark side right the undead Army it
changes everything because Mr mixoped
like this guy can alter reality just
with a snap of his fingers this guy can
go Toe to Toe with the most powerful
beings that exist out there in DC and so
this is kind of a worst case scenario we
don't know the full totality of his
abilities and we don't even know if he
can access his true power anymore but
the important thing here is that with Mr
mixopitalik becoming part of the undead
Army he destroys the planet of bolivax
Vic now there are a couple reasons why
the superheroes even responded to this
world in the first place when the undead
Army was heading there there's really
only two main reasons the first is
because of kilowog who's a member of the
Green Lantern Corps and the fact that
it's his own home planet and it's more
or less the Green Lantern saying we will
Ally with you because you're one of us
and we'll do everything we can to
protect your home world the other part
of this was just self-preservation
bolivax Vic is home to 16 billion people
with a B you're talking about an army so
vast that it bolsters the existing
vastness of darkseid's Army and makes
Conquering the universe all the easier
and so for the for everybody who really
wasn't a Green Lantern and didn't really
even know kilowog on a personal level it
really required their intervention
because had they not stepped in
presumably 16 billion foes or 16 billion
people or so would have bolstered the
army of Darkseid such as it was they're
all dead right so I guess it's kind of a
zero sum now if you're a person who
lacks empathy like hey dead man can't
fight a war so that's basically what
this is now but at the end of the day
there is a bit of somberness that comes
in the aftermath of this and the
destruction of this entire world hits
Superman hard because for the second
time over the course of DC's and even
the second time in his life in this
alternate reality story he has to
basically watch a world fall the first
time it happened was when the outbreak
happened on earth right when like
everybody on Earth was either becoming
infected or they were killed or they
managed to escape they managed to flee
but like that was it right human like
Humanity just regular people there was
no real hope for them there was no real
saving them and so Superman did what he
could where he could but even he fell to
the power of the undead of the the
anti-life virus and so when that
happened of course ultimately he was
saved hence the reason why he's here now
but this is the second time he has to
watch that happen now one of the funny
things about this is that it's easy to
look at Tom Taylor's writing and see him
as a guy who's really just kind of
writing off Superman as like incompetent
right or a guy who just can't really do
anything effective in this universe
because he sucks but that's not really
the case the truth about it is you kind
of have to look at the actions of
Superman both in a micro and a in a
macro sense when it comes to like
Superman operating in a micro sense he's
in Metropolis and sometimes there's foes
around the world that he faces off
against and that's it but when it comes
to Superman operating on a macro level
right on a great big huge larger level
especially in a universal space he can't
be everywhere at once and he can't save
everybody all at once despite Superman
almost appearing as this kind of Larger
than Life figure he's not he's just a
person who's got some powers and he's
really capable and he does cool stuff
sometimes and that's it and so it's one
of those really cool ways to kind of
bring his character down and remind us
as the reader this guy's not some some
Unstoppable force and watching a world
perish when he feels like he could have
done something to save them it hits him
all the harder not only that you've also
got Kyle Raynor who's struggling here
right now remember Kyle Raynor is one of
the four Green Lanterns of Earth you've
got Kyle Rayner Guy Gardner Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart Jon Stewart and kilowatt
are dead right they're out so literally
like Kyle Raynor is watching the people
that he calls friends perish right in
front of his eyes and so it's really
just one of these instances where this
destruction of this world happened at
such a time to where it strikes a
massive moral blow at the superhero
Community but here's the beauty of
Superman right Superman is pissed this
guy is incensed and in fact despite the
fact that they're seemingly so far away
from each other both he and Darkseid
lock eyes on each other and for a moment
Superman is ready to race off and face
off against Darkseid directly but if he
did that he would fail there'd be no way
for him to come out on top of that fight
assuming that it's just him and dark
side it's literally Dark Side empowered
by a Yellow Lantern ring he's a member
of the Sinestro court that doubles the
amount of power that he normally has he
would absolutely Crush Superman now when
you add in the fact that members of the
undead Army include Supergirl Kara
zorrell who's more powerful than
Superman is than all these other
different individuals out there all of
whom have different varying levels of
power sometimes comparable to Superman
sometimes a little less powerful and the
case of Mr mixopitalic even more
powerful no way this guy would win it
would literally be a Fool's errand it's
a suicide run and so he does the next
best thing he literally takes all that
anger he channels it inward he tells
Kyle it's not lost we can still do
something he turns it into hope and
that's the power of Superman the power
of Superman is that all the anger and
the rage that we as people would
normally feel and we would spew that
anger and rage out into the world on
Twitter or Reddit or something like that
and do nothing to make the world better
Superman does the opposite Superman's
response is like yes I'm full of anger
and I'm full of grief and I'm full of
sadness but I'm going to channel that
into something productive right I'm
going to become like I'm going to do
something good with it and then he goes
out and does that and so again it's one
of the one of the small differences and
really kind of the Hallmark of what
makes Superman Superman and so following
that if we switch over to Mr Mitchell
pidlick and the Specter now this is a
fight for the ages right this is a
massive battle a really good example of
this if you're familiar with Marvel
Comics it would be like Protege versus
The Living Tribunal right Protege has
the power to copy the powers of anyone
he sees and there's no limit to the
level of power that he can copy so much
so that he became as powerful as a
Living Tribunal it's like these two guys
facing off against each other you can
only imagine the level of power that's
being displayed here like quite
literally they're creating black holes
they're tearing in the very fabric of
space the impact of their punches is
enough to shatter the planets around
them right like suns are going Supernova
it's crazy how intense this battle is
now the Green Lanterns try as they might
fire off their Green Lantern rings they
try to restrain trained Mr Mitchell
pitolick he kills every last one of them
and by all standards of measurement this
is a losing battle right it is a losing
fight the the average person cannot
possibly stand a chance to even hold
their own in a battle between these two
Titans so it really just comes down to
Mr mixopitalic and the Specter to see
who ends up winning but here's where
everything goes south yet again yes you
guys know how it is of Tom Taylor just
when you think the heroes have a chance
to win things go belly up yet again so
Brainiac basically arrives here now of
course Brainiac has historically been a
Superman villain but in this instance
the enemy of my enemy is my friend the
the desire for self-preservation makes
every Survivor Across the Universe
whether they were former enemies or not
they're all allies now they're all
working together just to try to keep
themselves alive and destroy the undead
Army so Brainiac showing up here is well
one they've already met with him before
but him but who him showing up here and
arriving on Earth too which is kind of
like the backup Earth the second Earth
after the first Earth fell that it is a
way for them to kind of Marshal and
bolster their forces the problem with
this is that the arrival of Brainiac is
met with the arrival of scot-free right
Mr Miracle the guy who can break out of
any prison anywhere the issue with this
is that he is traveling with a mother
box and as soon as Brainiac sees this
he's like that why did you bring that
here because the mother boxes are all
connected he literally tells them it's a
giant Network what you're doing here is
ringing the dinner bell you're telling
everyone that we're here it's like
literally as soon as the mother box
pings and the infected realize where
they are a boom tube opens and they all
come pouring out led by high father
right the leader of the new Gods one of
the most powerful beings out there in DC
and yet another guy whose power
depending on the story rivals or
sometimes even exceeds that of
Superman's so now you have all these new
Gods who are just pouring out onto Earth
too and they're attacking all the
superheroes right like it seems like
it's all going Belly Up you've got
you've got their forces who are showing
up on the scene in it's it's open season
right it's a slaughterhouse Humanity
like you have like Batman and you have a
few other people trying to get people
out where they can when they can but one
of the people that falls here is Leslie
Tompkins now I told you guys what was
what was likely going to happen here and
Alfred does not become a Green Lantern
but I told you guys something was going
to happen with Alfred that Alfred was
going to in some capacity be the main
focus of the story or just something
something nuts would take place with him
and so what ends up happening here is
remember Alfred and Leslie Tompkins they
have a relationship together they're in
love right like it's like for the first
time in a long time Leslie represents
the possibility for Alfred being able to
have a happier life after having to kill
Batman when he became infected having to
kill Nightwing and and what was it uh
Tim Drake having to kill him well they
all became infected having to basically
kill his sons it tore him apart but when
Damien Wayne survived and became the new
Batman and Leslie Tompkins fell in love
with Alfred and Alfred fell in love with
her it was a shot at happiness and now
that shot's been ripped away now it's
been pulled away from Alfred so
literally what ends up happening here is
we transition back over to the fight
between mixopitalic and the Specter and
so literally what ends up going on here
is Superman realizing all the Specter
needs is an opening that's all the
Specter needs is the ability to just get
a shot in that can destroy mixopitalic
Superman hits Mr Mr mixer pivulik head
on not enough to destroy him but it's
enough to distract him and with that
opening the Specter stabs Mr M Through
the Heart Right Mr mixer piddle he stabs
him through the heart but mixopitalic in
turn reaches Into the Heart of the
Specter and rips out Jim Corgan now Jim
Corgan is the host because remember when
it comes to the Specter he's just the
embodiment of God's Vengeance or God's
Wrath depending on what comic and what
reality the comic is taking place in but
the important thing here is if the
Specter is not bonded to a host he just
kind of floats out there into The Ether
and that's basically it that you the
Specter has to have somebody to be
attached to in order to be able to act
and in order to be able to do anything
there was a story there have been
stories in DC Comics where the Specter
is able to act without a host but that's
not the norm and Tom Taylor's kind of
following the traditional standard of DC
which is the Specter needs a host to do
something and so as Jim Corgan literally
laid dying just out there in space that
the Specter having no host whatsoever
Alfred has to like watch on as Leslie
Tompkins dies and then in turn you
basically have high father who steps in
and high father shows up on the scene
Damian Wayne jumps in to do what he can
where he can as Batman but he's no match
for high father all they're really doing
is buying time here the reality is that
high father will kill them all he will
eradicate every single person here
they're all going to die and in fact
when high father hits Damian Wayne
Alfred steps in and just lets out this
unrelenting scream now here's the thing
right this whole thing is told from the
perspective of Alfred he says I didn't
even realize I'd moved all I knew was
there was a scream a scream I can
contained when that little boy lost his
parents in an alley so long ago a scream
I held in as I ended the lives of three
men I loved a scream of defiance of
grief but mostly of Fury and in that
moment I heard an echo of my anger
across the cosmos there was a Harmony of
rage and Alfred becomes the new host for
the Specter literally out like Alfred
becomes Specter and it is dope because
as soon as that happens the first thing
Alfred does he kills High father on the
spot and if Alfred can kill High father
Alfred can kill Darkseid and Alfred
could quite literally turn the tide to
the war with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end Cliff
Riders thank you all for watching I will
catch you all later peace